wir haben die 25 Fragen gestellt die
wurden dann tatsächlich beantwortet und
nicht alle waren befriedigend das stimmt
einige waren auch sehr bekannt das war
auch vieles mit nicht erinnern das heißt
noch Zweifel ja das kommt darauf an wie
man das birgt halt in der Abwägung am
Ende kommt es ja darauf an was ist
beweisbar und was ist nicht und wenn ich
die gesamtabdeckung treffe gibt es
keinen harten klaren Beweis für die
Vorwürfe für die schweren Vorwürfe die
gemacht wurden sind in den in den Medien
auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen
Seite 35 Jahre her seitdem ist es ist
übrigens auch ganz interessant gewesen
die Woche wurde ja viel auch
recherchiert und nachgefragt seit diesem
Zeitraum er war 16 damals hat sich keine
Veränderung ergeben hat sich nichts
Neues ergeben und er hat in dem Fragen
und das war für mich sozusagen mit sich
auch der entscheidende Punkt gesagt dass
dieser Prozess von damals etwas
ausgelöst habe in ihm selber seine
Vorstellung zu verändern und in den
persönlichen Gespräch war so dass er
sehr angefasst war ich habe gemerkt dass
sie eine sehr betroffen hat und das war
für mich schon ein ganz wichtiger ein